tel tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono felice oggi siamo sul settimo
e penultimo episodio che pietro non vi
abbiano armato fino adesso ma forse alla
fine ci arriveremo chiudetevi il video
di quell 80 io proseguo io vado avanti
i veri youtubers proseguono ci vedo
ancora 79 pietro c'è qualche problema
arriva ancora 79 allora amico se messo
male amico arrivano invece voglio andare
avanti per vedere quanto risk a
staccarti che sa farlo a gara sto gioco
avevo finiresti amicizia io sono io alla
fine anche si sta qua 81 a ecco c'è un
buco c'è un blog ha trovato c'è un buco
sotto le sotto seggi by di sotto c'è un
muro
non so spiegare tel aviv quota player al
primo tentativo amico di questa parte
veramente difficile no che infamata
ragazzi nov aveva le do una pianta
rimettersi trappoli sono infamata dopo
fortunatamente non ti fa fare tutto il
livello di nuovo guarda ce l'ho fatta
dai vieni prof.re questo aspetto eccolo
è un casino solo capire cosa devi fare
il suo livello
gli stili velli in realtà perché sono
poi i livelli che non capisco cosa devo
fare in realtà lo sono io che sono
diventate scemo
bene o male ci hai fatto io sono avanti
sono tutte mi senti silenzio perché sono
concentrato con pomodoro dai che ti
diverti 1 le battute molto amico mi
divertono tantissimo guarda come sono
divertito molto bene 83
c'è allora questo lo vedo arduo perché
c'è un uovo d'oro a puo entrare i bookie
non ho poi treni bus si rispetti la mia
promessa è vero che figo
ma tolto la vita mi sono fatto male
anch'io pensate di questa parte
veramente difficile però stiamo
arrivando
mancano 17 livelli ragazzi ma sono
veramente ebook da aumentati di cold e
si sono vantati difficoltà ci sta ci sta
si chiama sono le sfide o flight of
flight of ai no ma tu con effetto sono
davanti tutti infiammato
ma tu dietro il denaro dietro i tecnici
che c'è un bellissimo vc incrociamo del
carro grafia coreografia o my dad se 84
e se dai focale tnt per qualche strano
motivo pensavo anch'io
io vorrei provare a dar fuoco di
renderti in qualche modo sono non farlo
adesso però perché potrebbe essere un
casino spaccheremo la muffa perfetto che
player che player keplero del mondo
stavo passando anche io no ma non sai
neanche chi è ma smetti che play
verranno youtube guarda che bravo qua
madonna mi sono accorta la fine che
erano slime keplero erano di tuber csm
mi sembra ovvio no non citava 3 php
io sono simpatico dai che ti faccia
ridere dai quattro ai ripidi per mai
sorridendo per l'esasperazione riporta
questo gioco non si fa questo salto è
finto o report emesso sei ore però vabbè
dettagli ma anche se riesco a fare sto
salto fatto bene o ce l'ho fatta sono
forte mamma mia sono caduto sulla morte
la mia vita fa schifo allora occhio che
poi c'è un buco c'è un bruco
se cadi giu un casino non arriveranno e
se tutto si sta roba qua
ciao 86 stai zitto 0 liberamente sul
cuore riuscito a salvarsi con mezzo
cuore madison cuore che ammiro amico mio
grazie davanti a kimi mi guardi che mimì
ricevi una no ti ammiro
e vabbè aviv che i giocatori sono anche
tu ma tu puoi essere così egocentrico e
avere il tuo nome sulle spalle ma
neanche superman ha scritto superman sue
spalle davanti ma è solo e che è meglio
la metti è la e di amiche meticcio è nel
fumetto la rete di pane e di qualsiasi
altra cosa è certa che devo entrare
usare lo slime perfetto non sarà che
come ho fatto a farlo giusto oppure
scritti amiche dietro la schiena
mamma mia va benissimo sono bravissimo
bravissimo bravissimo sono forte
mammamia amico e da finisce così da sei
tu lamentarmi di stato e arrivo e che
non so dove stiamo andando ora che lo
guardi c'è una torre nel mezzo e
fighissima sta roba
vieni io non ti guardo più non so come
avrei voluto evitare novella ho capito
ho capito ho capito
ok è perché perché ci avevi fatto che
lascia seguito le 6 è sono morti nel
capitolo ok ok è praticamente no niente
ci stiamo vedendo solo occasionalmente
nel 2t praticamente ormai noi ci vediamo
ogni tanto quando capita se come un
caffè via porca vacca rimasto con un
cuore tutto questo bravo
non era difficile ma va bene bravissimo
quanto sei forte
adesso un bel casino cosa ti ho un po
devi bagni appare a non aspettatevi
usare il coniglio per arrivare fino all
mamma mia che casino con primo tempo
ancora no ma che ruota fa questa roba a
infinito che abbiamo e speriamo sia
infinito ok ok sono sopra ma che
facciamo
guarda studenti di qua ma chi l'aveva
vista sta roba
bravo bravo così mi piace da sempre cup
è stretta e qui chiappe strette non è
paura
no assolutamente no bike no secondo me i
ragazzi pietro è caduto ma si finisce
prima o poi sta roba
ora è finito una spirale bella lì è però
non vedo la fine ancora ma basta quanto
parkour nella liga ok ok ok ok ora secca
di qua guardava giu ma stiamo scherzando
muore chi fa tutto livello provaci no no
no no
ora i giri e lo faccio no no no no non
ti tocco giuro su no no no no le mani su
una signora le mani sulla tastiera non e
cosi
che cosa vuol dire è vero che si
appoggino nyman manifestarsi mai ancora
v'è ancora applausi
accidenti pare che l'aveva fatta di un
po bravi a cuore a calare ancora
hai avuto paura quando si guarda che non
è finito il livello a gonne come una
signora morin sonori mori però non sono
caduto a livello 88 80 si è poi così
eh sì ragazze mamma carico quando vedi
un checkpoint ragazza sorpresa di questo
mondo
o ce la fa ma ogni tanto sono spaesato
non capisco dove sto andando però che
come come si fa questo salto della
conchetta offerto mamma mia ragazzi che
che cos'è questo effetto questo insieme
fortissimo sono saliti uno speed runner
te lo giuro
ok 89
da allora cliccate 89 ragazzi quasi gli
ultimi dieci livelli
mamma mia che ansia allora adesso ti
aspetti in un posto no non riesco a
farlo suo livello senti laila a me la
lav ambiente anziane non mi aspettavo
mai fai le cose che ho detto trasporto
in un posto ecco è ok ora dimmi secondo
te dov'è il passo di segreto bravissimo
a essere ok ok ogni cosa con degli scali
davanti ad esso rimane la serie tipo
dora l'esploratrice dov'è il passaggio
segreto
cosa facciamo
non sono sicuro però lo faccio lo stesso
e l'ho fatto ed è giusto ok ragazzi no
boh cosa ho fatto cose sono bravo sta
andando avanti
non so come non sto capendo dove sto
andando ma io vado
ecco qui 6 p non è difficile
guardateci italiana sono alla liana io
ok io sto andando abbastanza avanti in
realtà non so dove c'e la porta
no no vieni qua ti pare
allora ok giusto non toccare il bordo
bravissimo è ma ora che era veramente
una cacca globali a una porta
lol ormai le soluzioni più semplici non
invece il cocchio che secondo me è una
presa per il leader ethan questa ma chi
se ne frega loren o questo l'inizio
sapevo lo sapevo ma guarda guarda che se
casco la prima volta quando a riaprire
la porta ma stai dicendo mi hai messo
ansia noi veterani punti difficili ok
sono tutto sopra anch'io
ok veramente io ho paura del salto non
di te brano è invece sbagli o prezzo
cosa c'è molto bene allora qua non so se
quello che penso
vinci di andare direttamente allora uno
va direttamente una sorta sulle salme si
fa tutto in allora allora posso posso
darmi la carica si va bene
bravo bravissimo è sicuro che non era
per salto 90 sono bagnato dal sudore di
giocare con quello schifoso
non è vero ti voglio bene pietro ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto l'ottavo
episodio sarà l'ultimo quindi ragazzi da
un bel haj voglio carichi per l'ottavo
episodio di vederlo anche la nonna
perché ci siamo fatti quella parola lì
che non posso dire per arrivare fino qua
mi piace anche ai vari social che
coniglio dalla descrizione anche i miei
capelli bagnati
non sono quelli
cg bebè ragazzi
[Musica]